so we finally had the ability to turn
into a beast
in blood-borne in the old country I
thought this was going to be the only
transformation but it turns out I was
wrong here's a quick guide on how to
transform into a lumen wood in order to
become this alien-like creature you're
going to need the milkweed Road to get
the milkweed rune
you're going to have to help out the NPC
you see in the research halls who's
strapped in a chair in a corner you soon
find out she was a saint before and that
if you help her she'll give you Saints
blood if you need it she wants you to
get her brain fluid so that she can
continue to dive deeper into her vision
there are two brain fluid you can
acquire within the research halls one is
found past an old man in a wheelchair
with a Gatling gun and a hundred that's
presumably guarding the creature around
the third or fourth floor once you get
past the hunter you can go ahead and
kill the monstrous blob and get your
first brain bored the monster will come
back to life so you can talk to it
before or after as it won't make a
difference
the next brain fluid will be found all
the way up top on the rafters in the
research halls once you get there go
ahead and proceed with killing it and
grab your brain fluid now take the brain
fluid back to our NPC friend and watch
her get high as hell off that brain pool
after giving her the second brain fluid
you'll notice she's no longer strapped
into her chair you hear some laughing
though and it turns out she's turned
into one of those blobs you had killed
earlier for brain fluid she can't seem
to shake the addiction and asks for more
brain fluid if you talk to her she'll
tell you she needs more brain fluid but
that she also might be brimming over or
it turns out you can kill her for the
third brain fluid and she'll come back
to life like the other blobs did give
her the third brain fluid and she'll
thank you for giving her purpose in life
and reward you with a milking room
head back to the hunters dream and equip
the milkweed room you've now turned into
a lumen wood or some type of weird
cauliflower wasallam now for good
measure equipped the cost parasite
weapon which you got from the orphan of
costs you'll now see that you have some
type of spike like arm attachment go
ahead and hit l1 to trick the weapon and
you'll notice it on both your arms your
melee attacks will now shoot out
tentacles and your l2 will charge up and
arcane explosion also you're leaping
attack will shoot out a tentacle from
what appears to be your mouth have fun
and looming would form and stay tuned to
games.com for more blood-borne to old
hunters cover
you